alors là c'est important de le dire
c'est un pari le vaccin grip saisonnier
il vient de sortir là par exemple j'ai
vu ça aujourd'hui pour la saison 2023
2024 en fait on fait le pari de
circulation des virus grippaux du de la
prochaine saison épidémie en février
parce que on regarde le les virus
circulant actuellement dans l'hémisphère
sud en imaginant que ce seront les virus
circulant dans l'hémisphère nord à
partir de l'automne prochain parce qu'il
y a un délai incompressible de
fabrication des vaccins et qu'il faut
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on met comme sous le
jeu donc ça laisse peu de temps
effectivement aux pharmaciens et au
gouvernement pour décider jusqu'à
maintenant c'était les pharmaciens qui
commandaient tranquillement et de façon
tout à fait responsable leur vaccin en
tenant compte de leur patientèle de du
nombre de personnes qui qui faisaient ce
qu'il faisait vacciner entre parenthèses
j'en profite pour dire que les Français
ont parfaitement compris l'importance de
la vaccination saisonnière contre la
grippe on a maintenant une bonne
couverture vaccinale en particulier des
sujets les plus âgés qui ont pris le
réflexe d'aller en officine pour se
faire vacciner tant mieux il y a encore
un point faible ce sont les personnes
adultes relativement jeunes avec des
pathologies chroniques qui ont des
facteurs de risque de grippe notamment
c'est pas une maladie les femmes
enceintes qui sont qui peuvent faire des
formes graves et qui ne le savent pas
forcément et donc là encore il faut
qu'on arrive à embarquer ces populations
dans dans l'adhésion avec session grippe
alors comment ça se passe il y a
l'anticipation en 2020 c'était
particulier on a eu un contrat santé
publique France de compléments d'État
c'était totalement inédit et on l'a
reproduit en 2021 2022 ce qu'on peut
faire c'est évidemment se rapprocher des
des
commandes des commandes on va dire de
classique de d'officine pour essayer
d'anticiper le d'anticiper la saison
mais la grippe étant quand même un des
virus les plus mutants qu'on connaisse
on peut avoir des surprises il y a des
années 100 alors typiquement 2021-2020
2021 c'est quasiment été des années sans
grippe la probablement aussi du fait
d'une certaine compétition virale ou du
de l'efficacité des mesures barrières et
donc c'est très difficile d'anticiper
les saisons grippales mais plus on aura
d'adhésion des populations qui ont une
indication et plus on aura de vaccins
efficace et de discussion entre
l'ensemble des experts plus on essaiera
de d'anticiper au mieux les saisons à
venir mais vous avez noté que cette
année comme en 2017-2018 on a en plus eu
une épidémie étrange puisqu'on n'a pas
eu un seul pic mais on a eu deux pics
avec deux virus différents d'abord de la
grippa puis de la grippe B donc vous
voyez que on peut se faire surprendre
encore par la grippe qui reste un des
grands mystères viraux